Trong khi điều trần dễn ra đêm một trình tháng người theo dựa điệp hương,
Quốc hỏi về rù đã tiến hành bò phía lệnh tội tổng thống như Nà Buluatê và phê chất bà hỏi gần bị hình dại.
Chủ tịch Quốc hội Hội Hội Hội Sê Harry thông báo,
một trong 18,000 tổng số 1,2,2,2,4 đã bò phía tán thành việc lẫn tội tổng thống của Ló A T.
Cục bò phía dễn ra trong buổi cạnh, Bà Buluatê bị đánh giá thiếu nâng lực đạo đức.
Quốc hỏi đã chủ tập bà có mặt để tự viện hộ tuy nhiên bà Buluatê đã phùng xuất hiện tại phía điều trần,
sẽ nến việc các nghị sĩ tiến hành quy trình về trất nhìn trống.
Ngày xó khi Quốc hội nhất chỉ bãi nhận bà Buluatê,
chủ tịch Quốc hỏi hội Hội Sê Harry, Mà Bítang Tội,
đã chính thích nhận chức tổng thống thị bởi của Bero,
kể từ năm 2019, phát biểu tuyền thẻ chức Quốc hội,
ông hình định sẽ tuyền chiến về các măng đàn tội pham,
thể hiện các tiếp cận tình sản đối với tình trạm bất ổn giá tăng.
Bà Buluatê đã phay đối mặt với nhiều chi trích,
vì không kiếm chế đuất tình sản tội phạm sát tăng.
Những kì của Bà Bắt đầu từ tháng 12,
năm 2020, cũng đã chính kiến nhiều cuộc biểu tình và đối.